Police Officers and the Color Blue
Police services like the NYPD and the LAPD
are bona fide pop culture staples that have
been featured in countless movies and TV shows.
Their distinctive blue uniform is known the
world over, but have you ever stopped to think,
“Well, why is it blue?”
If so, wonder no more.
It turns out, beyond some of the modern reasons
for continuing to do it, there initially was
a very simple explanation as to why blue was
chosen.
For starters, why they keep the colour today-
according to “The Psychological Influence
of the Police Uniform“, the colour blue
has several functions in relation to a police
uniform, one of the main ones being that it
is much easier to clean and maintain than
a lighter/brighter colour and that it shows
stains and marks less easily.
Intuitively, this makes a lot of sense.
If someone was thinking of buying 18,000 police
uniforms, they’d probably want to buy the
ones that were easiest to clean.
Also, nobody would trust a police officer
in a dirty uniform unless he was currently
holding a kitten he’d just pulled from a
fire or the like; decking officers out in
a uniform that doesn’t show stains easily
is just good common sense.
Another reason listed by the boys in blue
today is that the dark shade of navy blue
makes an officer harder to see at night, making
it easier for them to sneak up on bad guys.
In fact, in 1996 Baltimore County police officers
working the graveyard shift stopped wearing
white uniform shirts for that exact reason.
Of course, whether this is really helping
the officers or not is up for debate.
This change wasn’t backed up by studies
or research of any kind, but to quote one
of the officers involved in the switch “The
officers feel safer with the dark shirts on
at night.
It’s the perception, and the perception
is as important as reality.”
Speaking of psychology, according to a study
done at the University of Georgia on 98 test
subjects (Color-emotion associations: Past
Experience and Personal Preference), the colour
blue subconsciously evokes feelings of comfort
and security in most people, supposedly making
it a good choice for people in a position
of authority to wear.
Now, we should point out that colour psychology,
while currently being heavily researched particularly
by marketers with compelling results, is not
yet fully understood, so take that previous
sentence with a pinch of salt (or perhaps
a mug full).
So up to this point, it’s really just been
a matter of practicality and a bit of pseudoscience
in terms of why police wear blue.
But is that why police first started wearing
these colours?
It turns out there is a little more to it
than that.
As recorded in the History of the LAPD, when
standardized uniforms became a thing for the
police across America shortly after the mid-19th
century, years after the first state wide
law enforcement agency (now known as the Texas
Rangers) had been established in 1835, many
officers were simply given surplus (navy blue)
Union army uniforms to wear.
Conversely, in the UK when the 1829 Metropolitan
Police Act was brought into effect, essentially
creating the country’s first proper, paid
police force, they made the deliberate choice
to dress their officers in blue to contrast
with the, then bright red uniforms worn by
the British military.
This choice was made almost entirely to distinguish
the officers from military personal, and hopefully
help make them look more like regular people
on the street; it was also partially for this
reason that initially, the police in the UK
were unarmed.
In fact, for a time the police in the UK were
literally only given a rattle to call for
help with and a wooden truncheon.
Regardless of the initial reasoning behind
the choice of the colour blue for uniforms,
it stuck and as the uniforms in both respective
countries were redesigned and made more comfortable
and functional for officers as the years went
on, the colour scheme has remained, for the
most part, the same.
As you’re probably aware, not all police
officers in the states wear the traditional
blue uniform you’d see on a beat cop in
say, New York City.
This is mostly due to the fact that historically
each state was responsible for designing and
implementing uniforms for its officers.
As a result, not every state went with the
“just chuck ‘em in old Civil war uniforms
approach“.
In fact, initially, many police officers didn’t
even want uniforms due to the fear it would
make them a target of mob violence and ridicule.
(Not surprisingly, many officers saw fit to
arm themselves before guns became standard
issue.)
As an example of just how resistant to this
change some law enforcement agencies were,
the Orange County Sheriff’s office didn’t
make a uniform compulsory for its officers
until 1938.
Bonus Fact:
• Sports teams or athletes wearing red have
been noted to consistently perform better
in various forms of competition over the long
haul.
Why?
Well, no one really knows, but one study to
determine the root cause indicated the officials
may be at least partially to blame.
Specifically, “As part of their study, the
researchers had 42 experienced Taekwondo referees
watch two videos, each of which included 11
fight sequences.
In the first video, one athlete wears a red
trunk protector while the other wears a blue
one.
The second film shows the same exact scenes,
but with the athletes’ colors switched by
digitally manipulating the tapes…
On average, athletes scored 13 percent more
points when they were wearing red than blue.”